Patrick B David is is is is he's he's
much more direct he's a lot stronger on
these things than I am with his point of
you anybody who knows about his past
interviews knows he's going he's not
going to let you walk on this one he's
not going to give you the same leeway
that that I might I think they sabotaged
him on purpose they they they brought
him to a show and gave and and and gave
Val tment a layup to put a pair of boots
on a table oh come on yeah here we are
friends with some of the people who
worked for disantis in his campaign and
they they can't even come on the show
and I'm like that's weird man why we
talk to him we'd actually help like hey
let's work through these issues that
you're having and figure out ways you
can improve nah they won't do it yeah
I'd take the boot cut it open on air
with a knife and show you yeah it's a
cowboy boot and it's probably toes
aren't long enough so it looked like it
was bending still a cowboy boot no you
think he's
wearing inserts cuz some some cowboy
boots just have big heels on my Twitter
I posted a picture of me standing next
around de santis and and a picture of me
standing next to Trump and then Trump
standing next to the santis and in all
three pitches Ronda sanz's height has
fluctuated and I don't wear and not
boosters or there's when you watch
videos of him walking he's very
obviously one the way he's walking high
heels and two when the foot bends you
can tell that M he's wearing high heels
y i someone went to him and said put the
high heels on you'll look tall and
everyone and then they're laughing at
him like I can't believe this idiots
doing it and he won't fire these people
because they are sabotaging him on
purpose and this now again the Trump to
Sanda ticket a year and a half ago was
unbeatable absolutely they'd be Trump if
Trump announced sandis would be the VP
he'd be pulling it 52% or something
honestly if if the sers just bowed down
and had humility right now they'd still
be
unbeatable if you saw saw him
acknowledged the the I don't want to
sweare on camera but the last year of
his campaign if he acknowledged how
poorly run it was people would light up
I think that there's uh too much
animosity right now for a a trump
DeSantis ticket and I think part of it
has to do with the infrastructures
they're both surrounded by because you
would need to merge their teams or one
of them would have like the Sanz would
have to abandon everyone he's been
working with I don't know that that's
realistically going to happen maybe it
should so I I don't want to force anyone
into drama but why is it that there have
been three people who have come on this
show who have asked me why am I being
attacked by desantis's campaign and and
so there are individuals who are not
hyperarid whose careers do not put them
in the line of I'm for Trump or I'm for
we've had people on the show who are not
saying either of those things and
they're like the S campaign started
attacking me and I'm like yeah they're
trying to destroy his campaign they want
to make they're going scorched Earth
they want to make sure
that if in 6 months it clearly is Trump
there will not be a recovery period like
Ted Cruz had Ted Cruz was lying Ted and
then after the primary he was lion roar
Ted lion instead of lying pry that's the
recovery that's pretty good insight and
his sadness beard that was a time well I
can speak to that too right look what uh
you know when when this first all
started I I wasn't uh negative on to
santis at all and and I'm known to be a
trump supporter right but then you had
JD Vance come out and say you know leave
it to sanz's poorly run team to attack
their former friends right and that's
exactly what they've done but but see
the thing is they attacked people who
were currently their friends yeah I like
I've had people prominent individuals
say to me I they like ask me like hey uh
do you know what's going like I'm being
attacked by the sis people do you know
why and I'm like I'm like they're
attacking everybody and it's just
they're just like I I don't understand
like I've not said anything bad about
him at all right and I'm I just I think
the idea is after the primary they want
to make sure that not a single Trump
supporter will welcome to santis back
yeah there's no explanation for why some
of these personalities are prominent
individuals with a lot of followers
there's no explanation for why they're
like I can't stand a Santa you know I'm
why would you attack some of these
people like why did they start attacking
us why did they ban their people from
coming on the show if when Ron loses
there's a recovery period where Trump
can say enough fighting you know Ron's a
great governor and we're going to
welcome him back anymore there's not
he's going to be Rosie Odon yeah exactly
it is so toxic and the high heels thing
was the nail in the coffin there's no
way Trump can be like I'm going to
choose backstabbing high heel Ron with
the crackhead PR team it's it's not it's
not going to happen there's a reason why
they don't work for Trump anymore and
they deflect it over to his team I mean
y to Sis's crew yeah oh okay I he has
some smart people on his team but to I
don't think so they're not around
anymore though maybe they're just not
wise num two potentials the's people are
geniuses and what they're doing is
intentionally destroying Des santis or
they are the stupidest people in the
world and they don't understand they're
destroying to santis I think they
additionally no matter how you cut it
Ronda santis is the dumbest politician
in the country right now for hiring but
it's like firing them look look you can
you can hire bad people but after the
first screw up you have a talking to
after the second scrw you start saying
warning and you put out statements third
scrw up you say I have removed this
person from staff he's not done it
especially when your platform is built
on the you know the the preface that you
run a tighter ship than Trump right
Trump had all these leaks in the
warehous according to dis santis and he
runs a tight ship in Florida right it
just it's a it's a it's a direct uh
polar it's it's polar to what he what
he's campaigned on yeah I get the vibe
okay what I was going to say I think I
Ron strikes me as high intelligence low
wisdom because he doesn't know how to
get his intellect across it's poorly
managed and poorly integrated and like
you got to have humil dude and this this
obsession with pride of like oh they
said something mean get them like no you
got to like roll with it yeah you said
something mean cuz I'm a goofball that's
his team see I likeed into like his
Persona unfortunately you're right I
like Ronda Sanz I think he's done the
best job of any governor in Florida and
that's why so many people move there
that's why a lot of people are defensive
of him but that is it that is no excuse
for hiring the worst people imaginable
who are setting fires to everything
around you and you being like this is
fine at that point I'm like this guy has
a very serious leadership problem very
serious leadership and I'm you know what
I'm going to start doing sorry I can
only assume now the accomplishments of
Florida are to the legislature and he's
just going true I guess and he's he's
bumbling around like Mr Meo because
where he has direct executive Authority
his campaign he's failed miserably when
it comes to the politics of Florida he's
stamping what the Florida legislature
passes and so we give him a lot of
credit for it and for standing up and
making statements now I'm just thinking
you know they're probably just handed
him a script and he just says whatever
and in Florida they want to win they do
but here they're trying to tank him
knowing he can't beat Trump and they
don't want him teaming up with Trump so
they're sabotaging him or they want him
to stay governor of Florida and they
don't want him to be president so
they're trying to destroy his chances I
don't know that's a possibility it's not
it's not a great uh any of these offs
are pretty bad to have on your staff
right I mean this is not what you would
want to be surrounded by while running a
campaign yeah I mean but the
establishment to Tim's point is evil and
they'll you know they'll go to the
farthest lengths to destroy something
that they don't like well people were
pointing out like Ken Griffin donating
to Dan santis and the immediate
assumption is the establishment is
teaming up with d santis to go against
Trump and I'm kind of like or they just
are sabotaging Des STIs they do not want
an ascendant to Trump personality they
don't want an heir to the Trump Throne
if what was everybody saying Trump 2024
DeSantis VP DeSantis 2028 not anym than
not the Sanz is done I mean I don't know
where he goes after this he's he's
termed out of Florida maybe he'll Run
for the Senate so question then VP ramas
Swami or Kennedy ramas Swami ramas Swami
I personally want Larry Elder to bvp
I've got a job writing on it so you know
I like Byron Donald's to be honest but
yeah Byron's a good guy I love Byron
Byron's exellent really cool dude yeah
stand up guy he's endorsed my campaign
by the way um but yeah Byron Donald is
is one of the best people I met in DC I
agree absolutely one of the best people
in I mean there's there's so few people
but I actually met Byron Donald's when
he was hanging out with Gates and I'm
like I'm not surprised like these are
good dudes Lauren boer's office we
interviewed him it was really cool you
think that there's any weight to the
idea that Trump's going to feel
obligated to pick a female VP oh he
better not play this game that's what I
do not want him to play this game but I
keep hearing everywhere no it's
definitely going to be a woman it's
definitely going to be a woman and I do
not want that it makes me really mad be
sure to tell him that yeah as soon as he
calls me I'll be like if you put pick a
woman B PV you've lost everyone's
confidence we got to you know you know
like people kept asking us when we're
having him on the show and we know so
many people in Trump's Circle they've
all said like we can figure something
out we'll talk to him he's he'll
probably just say yes of course but we
got to go to him and we just we've not
coordinated it and tried to make it
happen I'm not saying Trump is going to
give us the time of day I'm saying you
know a lot of people around them are
like no no yeah we can we can work with
him and and and schedule something we've
just not done it we should probably just
finally do it and just get our like
booking people to be like can we just
arrange this finally because then I can
say you know Don just don't no no no
Nikki Haley
yeah I think that should let me let me
ask you I I think you know what I've
learned in politics is things kind of uh
are plated right on purpose I think
maybe that was something that leaked on
the back end to just test the waters for
what the general public would think and
what Twitter would think and I think
pretty quickly it got uh you know
smashed that you know he he needed to
have a a female vice president and I
think he's I think he's turned the page
on that I don't think V is the perfect
candidate I think he's the current best
option you know in the past I said
Carrie Lake but you know there were
several points that were made one in
terms of what is best for car Lake
running for Senate winning in Arizona
and helping fix the states we got to win
at the state we got we got to Winn win
the states um but also some other people
pointed out then you have Trump and
Trump basically Carri lake is a smart
like no disrespect to Trump but she is a
a a a sharper articulate Trump and so
people have said you need a contrast to
that and VI in a way is kind of like
Trump but he's a PR guy he is tactful
kind of like how K lake is but I'm in
terms of his presence that's why I kind
of feel like he's probably the better
option sometimes I want it to be a VP
that is not currently seeking the
presidency you know I know that's pretty
normal to to consider you know this how
we got uh Camala Harris of course but I
think yeah Pence wasn't running right
Pence wasn't running and again like not
that Pence was not the best option Pence
was forced by The Establishment man I
mean that's that's given but I don't
like it becoming too much of a of a
manufacturing line right it's like well
if you drop out early enough I'll give
you a VP I like the idea that there is
potentially other perspectives out there
that we don't hear on the national I
think I think V compliments Trump in the
fact that they have two totally
different leadership styles I mean
Trump's a transformational type guy
right he sees the big picture of a tends
to get in the details and you know they
they um they're Polar Opposites in so
many regards but personality wise they
do have some similarities yeah they're
both Executives I but Trump has the is
the executive and ramaswami is The
Mastermind yeah they're both masterminds
but ramaswami is a pure Mastermind yeah
I mean that's what he said when he was
here he was saying you know some
personalities just can't mesh well
together and I am a personality I've
been an executive for so long like I
have to be at the front and I think it
might be a challenge to be VP under
someone else it's not that he's not
talented and could do amazing things it
was just it's just hard for me to
imagine a trump R ramaswami ticket where
they're both happy at the end of thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a
member over at timcast.net